I want to thank President stump for
giving me an excuse to visit Greenland
I went from knowing nothing about a
country to falling in love with it in
three days special thanks to the people
of Greenland for their generous
hospitality and there are even more
generous portions of dried fish was
exciting just touched down in Greenland
and big crowd turned out to greet me
settle down everybody settle down
little known fact about Greenland
snowmobiles come from all over the world
to this area to mate it's a six-week
rutting season they've been going at it
you're resting right now I want to give
them their privacy young man what are
you doing into the table what's his name
Ian Ian Ian
okay I'm just gonna call Group Cup cuz
it's just all this master minute group
got group go what are you doing under
the table I want you to come up here and
tell us what you think about the
American foreign policy group go where
are you group go do what and my wife
cook what do you care you eat raw
reindeer liver would you care if someone
cooks you know what I mean you had an
you had an antler for breakfast and
you're asking what my wife cooks what
did you have like you had a carp eyeball
as a snack an hour ago I saw you eat a
rock on the way in you said that you
liked McDonald's yeah I'm gonna give you
this happy meal
this Happy Meals for you thank you the
only thing I will say is we bought it
three days ago and it's been sitting in
a plane okay it got a little hot in the
plane this has been smelling weird but
still that's my gift to you thank you
very much you gotta make American
Greenland also hat and you got a
three-day old rotting Happy Meal this is
the American dream
give the guitar over there what's that
all about sometimes you need to
just relax and take this heart take out
upgrade yeah I imagine it gets pretty
hectic around here and us anything to
sort of take the edge off you know we've
been sitting here for a while and your
phone has not run once yeah I know
there's cobwebs all over it when the
United Nations declared that you should
decolonize all your countries yep
Denmark figure out a different way to do
it
basically we were part of Denmark but we
were not part of Denmark because we were
used to be in colony in other words what
you're saying is there's something
rotten nasty and it didn't work but I
gotta hit that again cuz what you're
saying is there's something rotten in
the state of Denmark hey no more running
to 7-eleven for bags of ice America we
got all we need I mean this is nice but
incredible waste of advertising space
we'll take care of that
and I'm bringing you the latest weather
report for Greenland I will give the
reports in the Greenlandic language
let's face it how hard could it be
I'm fitting gun gurram be so a separate
memory you see canaller is I can assure
it to GU one of me thanks I'm assuming
in gorillas
[Music]